yeah
and I guess I uh shot your friend here
and uh he's not as fast as a speeding
bullet like the
Superman whoopsy days I'm sorry I'm I
apologize already on page one I
apologize bad joker take one B what do I
want what do I want what do I want you
know what I want
I want your little horny head on a big
old spoke what's the line and you have
none of your super friends here to save
you because uh you fired them all so
looks like it's time to
say real but you know what was manle the
Thugs who stole my sign from my sign
spinning job your Sid
spitter I'm a sid spitter there we go
this just really hard for me to hear
it's like finding out your arch nemesis
was one of those inflatable wavy arm
guys outside of a car dealership yeah
but no it was it was worse than that
because they stole my don't stop doing
that that Mak Deals Deals Deals stop but
you're a
clown because you worked as a
clown so you were clown clown clown
clown clown clown clown bad day with a
sign spin
evil clown when I went insane I thought
I'd just stay a clown yeah cuz insane
people are usually deeply
practical oh I've forgotten everything
so I actually killed my mom uh with a
pillow how' you know that because that's
the lamest candy ass way to kill
somebody do that sorry give him a second
I killed my mother with a pillow how did
you how did you know that because that's
the most candy ass way you can murder or
someone you fluffed your mother to
death a homicidal maniac was like a buff
buff buff like a 1930s Mafia
movie I dated my girlfriend for a whole
six months and then I found out she was
imaginary did you go to a different
school was she
Canadian did you have a picture of her
in your wallet and then one day one of
your Chums looked on the back and could
tell it was from 17
magazine I want to be crystal clear
about this
eat
[__] eat [__] in a hot dog bun you were
the coolest and then you were like want
to hear more about me and we're like
yeah
and then it
went give me that one more time it was
ours to
ruin nothing in his pockets but knives
and lint okay you want to know how I got
these scars then you pop up okay like
whack them all and you're like you want
to know how I got these scars I was
making a collage and I
slipped someone must have just cleaned
the floor cuz I just straight up slipped
her whoops while I was making my Crazy
Summer
collage you [__]
inel Mark Gotham deserves better puns oh
I have I have other stuff
um hold on stop assaulting Gotham with
your weak ass subreddit dad jokes okay
go home and Fade Into Obscurity with
some dignity tinkering away on your Rick
and Morty spec script well it's Sunny
script and it is funny oh I bet let me
guess Charlie accidentally joins the
clan oh can I have that no cuz I stop
it hey shut up we live in a society
that's your great contribution you're a
meme no one gets you're the herard gbms
girl get the [__] out of here you're
going to die worse than the Amy Kade G
bimp SC
[Laughter]
I
prefer Jared
Leto sry
sorry oh boy more
time I
prefer Jared Leto one more SM I almost
made
it I heard a giggle I
prefer that's
impossible I
prefer I'm sorry but [__] me that's not
possible it's not
[Music]
possible